on guys thank you so much for coming on
the stage the order 1866 there was a big
piece of london behind me which is
making me feel a little bit homesick and
you guys have shown off a bunch of
the folks at home who have gamepl seen
this game can you just explain what
exactly it is from a sort of a overall
standpoint the r1886 is uh is our take
on on our history basically it's an
alternate version of our history where
mankind has kind of split genetically a
long time ago and uh this war between
man and half breeds have been going on
for centuries now and we're joining
basically the game and the ip in this
game in 1886 where uh the knights are
fighting basically against the half
breeds uh this game does it all does it
take part predominantly in london or
entirely in london entirely in london
that's that was kind of uh
the drive at the beginning of the game
was to make london feel alive the way it
was back then awesome um it it looks
like one of those games we actually look
at the the gameplay of it now and it
looks like one of these games that is
people will look at as graphically the
reason to play a next-gen title the
stuff you're doing with them particles
and lighting is really impressive uh can
we can we go in and have a look at
something now absolutely
it's been a label of labor of lava i
mean since we started you can see from
the visuals and all that this is this
was the onus at the very beginning it
was to showcase what the playstation 4
could do
through this game visually graphically
technologically this was really the
drive behind creating this so what's
going on here in this scene just set the
scene for us
so uh uh we are basically uh seeing the
squad of knights in chapter three as you
see uh entering white chapel and
fighting against uh what's been
happening in london in the last few
years is the rise of the rebellion uh we
try to depict that rebellion the same
way that the uprise of you know uh
social classes happened back then so we
try to stay true to a certain a few
things from history but here uh the
rebellion uh group of just militia men
uh are take uh basically going against
the government at this time
you're having some controller problems
all right
this is a this is e3 at its best we've
got some we got some bluetooth
controller problems and let's keep going
it's moving on its own
i can't
all right come back to us we probably
got some b-roll we can go to or
something like that um yeah so so this
game it looks incredible uh visually uh
from what we've seen here from what we
saw at the uh the sony conference as
well uh it looks quite linear though is
this a very like scripted story
piece of storytelling or how open are
the environments you're in so yeah i
mean the idea for us was really to
basically uh uh you know
make it a story driven game uh
introducing an ip is always tricky you
always choose the medium you want to do
it with yeah you can go multiplayer you
can go you know co-op you can do
multiple things but for us the single
player path was the right one to
introduce the ip to the world for the
first time and you know let's see what
happens in the future but this game is
going to be linear you know story driven
game cool i want to remind the folks at
home if you have any questions at all at
danny or dwyer on twitter and i'll make
sure i get it to the guys here on stage
i've got a bunch of questions myself i
used to live in london i love white
chapel i used to go out drinking there
all the time did you guys go there to do
any like wreckies and see what the place
is like it actually took uh most of the
team all the artists all the animators
a lot of the guys on our team
being americans don't get out of the
country much sure so we took them all
there for it was a couple weeks
and with lots of cameras they took
literally tens of thousands of pictures
of everything we went to every museum
every you know they even got to visit
those abandoned you know 19th century
subway stations really yeah they got
we were lucky enough to get led into
places that are really representative of
that period and they were able to get
all this fine little detail about what
made
that particular era so interesting and
so colorful
to understand london just like you know
you do you have to live through it i
mean of course the time is not enough to
do that but it was amazing to see them
finally understand what it felt like to
live in london and what to your point by
the way to drinking we did that too
and we're showing this at the moment uh
over here the um
uh demo that you guys showed last night
so this is when you met one of the uh is
it fair to call them werewolves or
absolutely well lycanth werewolves the
interesting thing about this uh what we
showed yesterday and i think it was you
know we actually demoed them pretty cold
uh it was uh it was really like about
answering that question we posed a year
ago yeah we showed a trailer there was
figures behind the fog
and really the question was always what
was behind the fog the last answer to
that was what we showed yesterday the
reveal of the life and in our world
lichens are
you know again the evolution of mankind
where they've taken on traits like
lichens do and people have equated them
to werewolves because they look like
that okay are you so are you fighting
random humans and lichens are you just
fighting lycans and lycans in their
human form no you're finding random
humans in the rebellion okay and the
lycans as well we really wanted to build
a world that was not so black and white
you know not like one party against
another yeah but introduce that third
group that basically came into play
where everybody's fighting really
against each other all the time and
that's the tricky thing is like you have
humans to contend with but at the same
time you have all these lichens and
these half-bricks to contend with that
as well if you're just showing this kind
of stream we're playing the order 1886
uh we had a little bit of trouble with
the version we have here apologies from
us on that end uh but we're looking here
what you guys showed at the conference
uh so this is a situation in which it
looks like it's part of a sort of a
scripted piece of of gameplay how much
of that is is this sort of stuff and how
much of it is the um the open more open
environments that we were looking at
before
yeah a big part of the game is
pacing you know and we really wanted to
give the player a variety of of almost
different gaming experiences but all
seamlessly integrated together you will
do a lot of combat a lot of fighting but
then you will the mood will change you
will get into a place where there be a
lot more exploration like the the demo
that was done last night it's actually
maybe a 10 12 minute exploration phase
before you know with certain elements of
of cinematic you know power that come
through occasionally but last night they
were just rushing through it because we
had to get to the you know yeah i guess
that's appropriate for press conferences
as well as that's right so
but yeah i mean like as far as the game
is concerned it is that pacing that's
important and of course at the at the
core we are a third person you know
shooter yeah uh but we are going to meld
in a few different gameplay mechanics we
haven't talked about the reason we
introduced the like and also is to give
you kind of that idea that you can shoot
him but as you see as uh in the demo
that we've shown you don't really do
much to him by just using regular
weapons so we are going to show people a
different mode of gameplay that we
haven't talked about a lot that will
kind of deepen the the experience
overall and uh and at the same time for
us
knowing that the core is a third person
action adventure you know action shooter
we knew that people would understand
that what we really wanted to express
through the little bits we're going to
do in the press and marketing yeah is
really show what's the new things that
we're doing for playstation 4 and that
that's kind of the only the drive behind
doing this i guess when you're pacing a
game you also have to pace your
marketing to make sure that people get
the right message
you talked about the um uh weapons as
well one of the most incredible things
that i saw um in the piece of gameplay
that we that we had and
was the thermite
gone that effect of stuff
the way in which you can sort of light
up an area and keep it heated up and
what other types of weapons you're going
to have in the order
well there's going to be lots of them
we're not giving away all the details
since the next few months is going to be
really focusing on gameplay reveals uh
you're going to see a lot more but
there's going to be
a whole bunch of really cool weaponry
each one with a little twist just like
the the termite gun head so one of them
actually that you see in the game is the
arc gun the arc gun itself it's the it
basically shoots a lightning bolt the
interesting thing about this weapon is
that if you look and do some research
into all of them like we did all of them
are based on technologies that exist
thermite you can actually get thermite
and light it up and that's what it'll do
it'll just flare up and and it's
aluminum iron oxide that does that
the the the argon is just a twist on
what tesla's work was in the 18 in the
19th century in the 1800s where uh where
he was able to basically harness like
you know in so many ways like a bolt of
light of electricity what if you could
use that as a weapon every single one of
our weapons has that depth and has that
research behind it here's some of the
the thermostats absolutely as well you
notice when isabel shoots at the
beginning she literally fries one of the
enemies the lion gun like disintegrates
them pulverizes
accents yeah there's something to get
off destructible environments as well
absolutely and that's what the great
thing about the termite weapon the
termite weapon is a bunker buster is a
cover buster yeah you basically can
shoot over them even if they're in cover
and rain down fire to whoever's behind
them on the wall behind them or
something that's the twisting gameplay
scenarios but of course you have to be
careful with your ammunition because
you're going to run out very quickly
i've got an absolute load of questions
coming in via twitter if you have any
questions for the guys here at daniel
dwyer um
first question
somebody wants to know what your workout
schedule is
me how do you how do you make video
games and also be that oh it's uh it's
actually how it stays sane really oh
yeah everybody has to have he meditates
i pump iron but i like it you're like
the ying and yang of
having a good idea i've actually been
asked to uh i've actually been asked to
write a
series of videos uh which i call
bodybuilding from game developers that'd
be great i might i'm gonna work on it
next year
yeah you should do that we'll we'll
premiere it on gamespot.com believe me i
can deal with some work here what's up
and how often are the quicktime um
elements present in the gameplay stuart
hopkins asked it's uh it's very kind of
sparse uh the important thing for us for
the quicktime events is that it's not to
actually have them for the sake of
having them okay it's literally to have
them where we can build interactivity
into something that otherwise would be
non-interactive games have a tendency to
have very long five-minute
non-interactive moments we build those
quick times not as a you know it's a
necessity it's more of a well you know
that portion of that
normally what you would see as a
cinematic could be
interactable yeah so why not make
interactable that's why we added them
there we made sure that it didn't become
this kind of like heavy-handed thing
that we wanted to put in the game well i
guess graphically that what you have
here is the cutscenes in the game player
are quite they're almost identical they
are identical
so in fact
even everything that you see simulated
during the cutscenes in normal in games
especially games on the previous
generation what you had to do was
pre-calculate everything so you could up
the graphical quality as much as
possible thanks to the ps4 and thanks to
you know the extra reasons that we have
now
and the new technology we have now we
can do everything everything that the
characters interact with is still the
cloth or the way the clock behavior
changes the destructible things even
when they remove everything is still
simulated in real time and
technically speaking we can change at
will we could change costumes we could
change you know anything we want about
cinematics
excellent a question here from keelan as
asking is there any multiplayer in the
order 1886 is there any co-op or verses
or is this a single player it's a
single-player game uh you know i'll tell
you the truth when we started working on
this ip we explored every single you
know avenue what do we want to do for
this game to come out for the first time
you know the way we wanted to and of
course as much as we had that
conversation very early on we decided to
make this a single-player game a lot of
people from london are up uh in the
evening asking questions and this is set
in that you're obviously you've got
cultural touchstones here with london a
lot of it's happening
you mentioned tesla as well all that
stuff
questions jack the ripper and jekyll and
hyde is any of this stuff getting pulled
in at all all i can tell you is that uh
we needed to ground this in reality yeah
i mean very early on the story was
crafted so that there was so many
moments and places and people from real
the real world that would be injected
into this i want i'm really waiting to
see what the players are going to think
of it i can't really reveal too much
right now about what it is but you can
imagine that before that era it was one
of the richest eras in london actually
london was the center of the world
during that era we're going to make sure
that we're really delved into that depth
of
of the la the life the people and the
events of that world
why was it you went for this game you
could have you know you could i'm
assuming that you were presented with an
opportunity to make a game for a new
console you have this powerhouse you
guys have a lot of talented developers
at your studio why was it that you went
for this particular
place and time and this type of gameplay
how does that come from it's a very
simple answer it sounds trite but the
reality is that
rue is a you know history
geek i guess i can say that word he's
fanatical about this stuff and spent
many years developing this world these
characters
the grand vision for the game is
absolutely incredible the level of
detail and the extent and the scope and
the emotional punch that as a whole the
whole story arc has and when he
presented it to the team
we all loved it we all like you know
we we really like games that take us to
these kind of you know remote places in
history things that are really different
and uh it was just too exciting for the
team and that's how we work whatever
gets the most excitement on out of these
artists it's implicitly what we need to
pursue because it's what's going to
result into the most striking and the
most impactful work how long have you
been working on it already done
the game itself we've been working on it
now for a little bit more than three
years three and a half years
uh and uh stories i mean they were just
things that just we've been we've been
putting together for a long time it's
been it's been it actually has been a
labor of love because back in 2005 2006
just little short stories about the
world about
the alternate history all of those
things
melded into this game where in the
beginning it wasn't really just about
the audio was more of a of a timeline of
a lot of things that happened throughout
the last 2 500 years
and finding that thread through it was
really when this game started it's you
know drawing a thread through all these
events and all these stories all these
different characters all this lore the
myth and all that when that threat came
together is when we knew that we had
something that we were all passionate
about where every single person already
had done brings something to it and like
it becomes our world it becomes us you
seem to be very confident about showing
the game often at this stage obviously
it's something you've been working on
for a long time um what are what
how close are you to release and how
how eager are you to show more of this
game
we're very good to show more i mean
we're showing little snippets because we
have only a chance to show a small
snipper sure but at the same time i'm in
the game we announced the release date
yesterday uh the game is going to
basically be released uh on the 28th of
february 2015.
so the push that people talked about you
know it was only a few months it was
really for us to get a chance to deliver
on our promise of
making the game the way we wanted to and
deliver on the promise that we made
a very
wise friend of ours once said once the
game is on the shelf or in this case
it's ready to download now
all you can make is excuses for the
things you didn't get to do yeah and uh
you know we we had a certain vision in
mind that we wanted to make sure we had
enough time to deliver on the vision
that the gamers were expecting awesome
rue and andrea from reddittown studios
absolute pleasure to have you guys on
can't wait i'm going to actually i'm
actually done on this stage i'm going to
see if i can go queue up
and play 1886 you stick me in perfect
one perk i don't get much time on the
show floor i'm usually here so that
that's awesome it's worth it we have a
bunch more stuff coming up here in the
samsung stage i'm gonna go over to the
gamespot stage later i'm gonna be there
from four o'clock with skylanders sonic
boom lichtstein battle mage and a bunch